[Music]
do
[Music]
hey folks welcome to our second unity
2020
campfire i have two very special guests
i will introduce them
in a moment at first though i want to
tell you a little bit about the
structure of what we're going to do
this evening we have a tool called
democracy ai
that we are going to use to allow you to
give us feedback on what we're saying
and what you might like us to discuss
some of you have already interacted with
that tool
if you are not able to log into the tool
because you were after the first
thousand people to log in you can
dialogue about our discussion
at choose unity the hashtag is choose
unity
i believe the campfire will also be
live tweeted at that hashtag so you can
get into the conversation that way and
we will be looking at that
in order to see what might be visible
there
all right the democracy ai tool
is going to be used for one question up
front and then it's going to be more or
less quiet for the first
hour of discussion we will use it in the
second part of the discussion in order
to
source information from you all
so the question that we would like you
to answer is
can you identify and tell us about the
moment at which
you realized that drastic action of
the sort that unity 2020 represents
might be necessary
in order to rescue the republic
so uh while you are answering that
question if you're logged into democracy
ai let me tell you a little bit about
unity 2020 for that fraction of our
audience that knows nothing about it
and then tell you a little bit about
what campfire means and why we chose
that as a metaphor
unity 2020 is a plan to
recapture the white house on behalf of
the american public
in short we plan to draft two candidates
one from the left and one from the right
under the agreement that they would
govern as a team and
make decisions by consensus
uh the person who runs at the top of the
ticket will be chosen
by a coin flip after four years the
positions would reverse and the
president would run in the vice
presidential spot and vice versa
and this would go on until one party had
inhabited the office of president twice
and was therefore ineligible for another
term
at which point someone else would be
drafted into their spot
or until the american public saw fit to
do something else
all right so that's the basic plan it is
designed to
avoid the danger of spoiling the
election
by having a consensus government of left
and right
this will tend to drain both the major
parties of power rather than empower one
and disempower the other the reason
we've chosen campfire as a metaphor to
discuss this is that human beings have
long faced difficult problems that they
did not have the solution for
during the day people would typically be
out hunting gathering
farming and at night as their eyes were
no longer so useful
uh out and about they would gather
around
the campfire or the hearth and they
would talk to each other about what
problems they faced and what solutions
might be available to them and it is the
bringing together of different minds
with
different experience different expertise
that has allowed human beings
to conquer so many niches
all right now without further ado let me
introduce our guest
for this evening on the i believe it is
going to be the left part of your screen
you have nate boyer nate mcboyer is a
u.s army special forces green beret
he is a former footballer for the
seattle seahawks
he is co-founder of merging vets and
players
and he is also the colin kaepernick
knee whisperer have i got all that right
nate
you got it direct all right excellent
and on the right side of your screen
you have john wood jr john wood jr is a
former nominee for congress and he is
the national ambassador
for the organization braver angels
all right welcome to you both it's great
to be here it's good to see you brett
good to see you nick
you too john thank you brad good to be
here so
uh as we launch into this i would
actually
ask you both if there's a moment at
which you realized that the standard
tools that we are typically
handed in our democracy might not be
sufficient
to uh to steer our course this is
roughly the question we've asked others
to answer and i'm
curious whether you each can identify a
moment in your past when
when that became clear to you
huh so um
that's that's really an interesting
question when did we uh
when did i have the sense that something
was broken in our
politics i mean for me it's weird
because i i feel like i can go all the
way back
to my childhood in the 1990s and
i can remember even at that time
people saying washington is broken just
look at this
impeachment uh situation like the effort
to impeach bill clinton back during the
monica lewinsky uh scandal and i
remember at that time
people sort of lamenting the fact that
communication between the parties and
between the american people even
had started to decline in some uh some
radical way and you were seeing that
in the dysfunction in government and i
think that that was
true back then but you know those are
still like that's
those are the good old days looking back
at it from now in terms of
people's ability to get along and reason
together and work together
whether in congress or just in in
mainstream america
right um but um yeah but i had an
inkling even back then
as a kid that something was uh souring
the water
a little bit and that feeling has only
grown over the course of really my
entire
uh life and certainly my adulthood and
just kind of
observing politics and you know the way
we've done it for a while now
that's a great answer when we come back
to the discussion i want to talk about
this sense
um that it has only gotten clearer over
time i think it's an important one
but uh nate do you uh have a moment you
can identify
yeah you know i'm a little probably a
lot
greener when it comes to this
conversation
um and my i guess the amount of
attention i've paid to
the system itself and and democracy as
it stands and how
it operates or or in operates in our
country
um often and for me
it really didn't wasn't something i
focused a lot of attention on until
uh 2016. and it wasn't just
the election being that year i mean that
had a great deal to do about it
uh but it was more of a personal
situation
[Music]
with uh you know the the beginning of
the anthem protests in the nfl
started by colin kaepernick and i
shouldn't call them anthem protests
because they weren't
a protest of the national anthem but yet
a protest during
the national anthem uh bringing
light to social injustice and
the issues with police brutality and
lack of accountability
uh when officers are uh not doing what
they're supposed to be doing
and um you know i
i served for 10 years i was in i was in
iraq i was in afghanistan
i always thought of it as you know what
i'm fighting for the american people
my involvement in politics and even
really voting
uh isn't important because no matter
what i'm gonna serve the people
and i'll let them decide and i'll just
do
the job you know i'll do what i'm asked
to do for my country
um and so i never really
i never really thought about that i
thought about all this until
until that kneeling because i was after
the military when i played football
and i could tell you in a in a football
locker room in
the military in a team room the amount
of diversity
and different thought and beliefs and
backgrounds socioeconomic whatever you
want to call it
uh are very broad we're as diverse as
they come in both of those fields
yet because we go through stuff together
challenging stuff and i'm not comparing
going to war to playing a sport but
you know playing college football
playing the nfl there's a lot of
sacrifice that has to go into that as
well to be a lead just a different type
of sacrifice
so when uh
and we rise above all our differences
when it's time to play the game when
it's time to go to battle
we fight for one another the man on our
left and right woman on our left and
right
and we would do anything for them we
would take a bullet for them
we don't even always like them or agree
with everything that they say and think
and believe
but we know they would do the same for
us and that is what's
dramatically uh lost in our country
uh you know as far as
guests that love for one another and an
acceptance of differences and still
be able to work together so when i was
seeing when i was seeing this happening
with the election and then
when colin started sitting on the bench
in protest and it became
widely politicized um and it became
a once again an
act or a situation that was taken both
by
the democratic party and the republican
party and used as a tool
um to prove their point to prove why you
know why
they are the more righteous party or the
better party
and then you know we've seen that
obviously more recently with kovid and
whatever it is it doesn't matter
everything is politicized and it's like
is it it's going to be taken to the left
take it to the right
strong opinions about it so what my
real understanding of how broken things
were and how disgusting things were in
my opinion
where was through that situation because
i i wrote calling an open letter i ended
up meeting with him and it was through
our discussion
our conversation which was a pretty
open-minded one from both of us
we didn't agree on a lot um but we
listened to one another is
that's where the decision for him to
take a knee alongside his teammates
versus sitting on the bench isolated
came from
um and i thought that was pretty
powerful i thought that was actually
a good example of maybe how government
in some way should work
um when we have these situations like
compromises are made but everyone still
feels empowered and like they're
they have a part in this so it's a very
long-winded answer to your question but
i think it lays a bit of background and
for me it's really just been the last
four years that i've even really been
paying attention which
is kind of embarrassing but everything
happens on our own time i guess you know
yeah well it's actually it's a
fascinating answer for one thing
we have a lot of political dysfunction
in this country but
for folks in the military when decisions
get politicized
it results in people you know dying
and so it really raises the stakes
interesting that you're
awakening occurred after your service if
i understand your answer correctly
so i want to actually put these two
answers together though because
there's something quite
resonant for me and what you said nate
about the
politicization of everything and it
really is this this is the opposite of
patriotism
is to politicize things where in fact
the american public has an interest and
it's not being served because the
parties are
busy catering to special interests that
fuel them
and what they have us doing instead
is fighting over symbolism which is both
a distraction from what's real and
very destructive but if we then look at
what john said
john said that um the sense of
how off things were was clear back in
the uh the clinton administration which
i agree
i think in some ways that's where part
of this really began
but that it has only gotten worse over
time and that even the dysfunction
around the clinton years looks uh
tame at this point and so what i'm
constantly facing uh is the
suggestion unity 2020 is a
really good idea but we can't do it now
what we're facing is too important
and really the important recognition is
the one that john made which is
it only gets worse because it only gets
worse as bad as you think this is that's
an argument to do it now rather than to
wait
because doing it under even worse
circumstances and many people don't
believe that's possible but
boy is it um that will be even harder
yep yeah i mean if i can just sort of
throw something something on to that
first of all um
mate i appreciate um i appreciate your
analogy
about what it is like of course to
serve the military but also what it's
like to play on a team and the fact that
that sense of common purpose
it allows us to bridge divides in the
name of a shared interest right
in the name of the fact that there is
something in common that we are striving
towards even if we're
coming from different places and uh
brett uh to tie that to
unity 2020 here really quickly you know
the thing that excites me about
um what it is your what it is you're
doing here is the fact that
i see it as being about more
than just you know whatever candidates
you might
be able to get involved and rally around
it obviously has to do with the need to
to
shift um you know the status quo in dc
folks believe in that strongly um but
it but you couldn't have excitement
building around an alternative way of
engaging
an election in this context unless you
also have movement towards an
alternative way of just sort of
kind of animating our civic culture
really right how is it that we relate to
each other as human beings in america
now
i think we want to see political
movements that are based in this idea
that you have
human beings on different sides of the
spectrum and so nate you know the way
you humanize you know kaepernick's
um political demonstration i i get the
sense that maybe you don't
agree entirely with the way cap analyzes
things right
but you do what i consider to be the
patriotic thing what we call patriotic
empathy
at braver angels which is sort of
showing your love for your country by
extending understanding to your fellow
american
and so the thing that was inspiring
about say andrew yang's political
campaign for instance is that
you know he was running with sort of a
left-wing policy agenda he was saying a
lot of things that me as a more
conservative-minded individual
i'm a bit skeptical of but what came
through loud and clear
in yang's campaign just for instance was
this recognition of the basic dignity of
folks who exist
across the spectrum not just regardless
of race but regardless of partisan
affiliation
and philosophy and so forth and so it
seems to me that unity 2020
springs from that kind of need for a
shift in the culture and the spirit of
our politics
as much as it springs from a desire to
kind of sort of shift the way we're
engaging the mechanisms of politics and
so
i think that you need both if we're
going to usher usher for the type of
change that we want to see in political
society today
so yeah i mean i i agree i think
you know how binary we are right now as
a people as
a country as americans uh or at least
how we sing how binary are we seeing
um is is what hurts the most
because you know we've lost our
individualism
we don't we don't feel as though we can
speak our minds
because we're because we're constantly
being judged and attacked
um no matter what you stay and stand for
you just get attacked you just get
attacked there's just so much anger and
hatred
and like it's it's
it it doesn't feel it doesn't it's not
fun like
no one wants to live in this in this
world where we're walking on eggshells
constantly no one wants to do that but
what it's turning into
you know and it's it's uh we we tell our
kids
you know that money doesn't buy you
happiness don't judge people
you know never never there's a book by
its cover whatever it is we tell
we tell them this these things but we
don't live them we don't believe them
you know and uh and i don't think that's
everybody but that's the voices we're
hearing
that's who's getting the microphone
right now and so it seems like probably
a lot more people than it actually is
there was this sign that i used to see
when i was in
elementary school i think my one of my
teachers or maybe my principal had a
sign
up in her office that said everything i
ever needed to know i learned in
kindergarten
and being pretty close to kindergarten
at the time back then i sort of thought
there's no way that's true
otherwise why not let me leave school
now i'm in the second grade i should be
done with this
but as an adult you come to see what
that means the things that we teach our
kids
are the the values and the virtues and
the lessons that are most
important to sort of formulating
character right and showing them
how to treat other people in the world
if you want to be treated a certain way
and that's just that's sort of just the
starting point of wisdom
in in life from a certain vantage point
and yet it is precisely that basic sort
of thing you know the components of
interpersonal decency applied to civic
and social life
right that we've lost everybody is so
smart everybody has so much information
we have so many facts and figures
available to us at the
in our phones and our our and our
keyboards and yet
we've lost a lot of that basic sense of
you know
um the interplay of of decency and
dignity as being kind of
backdrop to a society that works and so
yeah man i feel like we need to get back
to things that are fundamental
i think we also you know i mean it's
implicit in what you both have
said but there is a certain
joy and intrigue in meeting people
who aren't like you people with whom you
know that you disagree about
important things but discovering that
they are very human and very relatable
sometimes surprisingly so
and what we've gotten to is a phase in
our
national dialogue in which the basis to
discover that
is being stamped out in other words all
of the middle ground positions
are being declared criminal such that
you can only inhabit these caricatures
at the extreme
and what it what it does is it really
literally
dehumanizes others in each of our eyes
and it makes it you know i think people
are just walking around
with suspicion of each other that
frankly i don't think characterized us
even you know a few years ago
you you could meet somebody and there
was awareness that you wouldn't agree
but that did not make them uh inhuman to
you and now
um the slightest hint that somebody
might be skeptical of some position
that you're certain of is enough to tell
you they are the enemy and that
you know not only are they mistaken but
that they're really up to no good
and this you know it's just not right
the fact is there are bad people out
there
but it's not common to run into them you
know sometimes you do and it can mess
things up but
in general you meet somebody and
they're decent and they're trying to
figure it out and they're probably
proceeding from
different data maybe different values
but they're not they're not bad
um so the assumption that they are is
just incredibly destructive
right i was at a politicon which uh
is a uh anybody who doesn't know it's a
convention out here in los angeles i
guess they didn't have it they couldn't
have this year because
you know nobody can do anything this
year um in physical space but
it's a convention where folks come from
all across the political spectrum to
just have a carnival
about politics right and so you know you
walk down a
hallway you see newt gingrich you see
you know david from
you see you know michael steele folks
from msnbc
cnn's on so forth i met this woman at
a um it was a satellite uh
broadcast of edward snowden live
speaking from his exile
just talking about you know the problems
of the surveillance state
why he did what he did and uh sort of
analyzing
you know the sort of the trajectory of
american
uh foreign policy and the way in which
uh you know the security apparatus is a
threat to our freedoms
and you know listening to snowden i
heard him say you know maybe some things
i disagree with but a lot of things i
i totally agreed with and uh when the
conversation was done
when the event was done i'm filing out
with other folks and um
this was not long after i ran for
congress so this was 2015. i just been
elected
vice chairman of the republican party in
l.a county
and there's a woman there uh who i just
struck up a conversation with talking
about what snowden
had talked about we shared opinions we
connected
you know we agreed on a wide range of
things and then she said something like
oh so uh you know what brings you here i
said oh i said well actually i said
first of all my name is john good to
meet you
i'm actually the vice chairman for the
republican party of los angeles county
and i said that as we were shaking hands
and she said oh she said that's
disgusting
and she sort of took her hand back from
me and she said have a nice day though
and she turned around and walked off and
i was like oh man
it's like a shot to the gut you know um
it wasn't the first time i mean look i
you know ran against maxine waters all
that wasn't the first time
um and you know i should say having
worked for obama's campaign before
that as a democrat got mistreated by
some republicans for sure
so it wasn't like these things had
happened to me before but when you're in
the middle of really connecting with
another human being and you get that you
know
it's tough and but i have to imagine
that this is an individual who's been
receiving a certain
kind of pejorative storyline just
streamed into her brain over and over
and over again 24 hours a day for
however long
to the point to where she can hardly
even see my humanity even though we are
connecting on this level because
the label just obliterates it and yet to
your point brett
every time i get into an uber you know
and i meet somebody who's either like
you know
burning bro or i'm in the south and i'm
talking to somebody who
you know might have a mega cap sitting
in the uh sitting in the passenger seat
or what have you or even like a
confederate flag on the bumper sticker
like
i i can i can always find if i just take
a little bit of time to look for it
something that shows me like this is
this is a decent person at heart or this
is somebody with some redeemable value
and usually have a great time talking
these folks wherever i might happen to
find them
but it's tough because the system as it
stands puts us behind the eight ball and
finding that humanity
so i think a lot of those people
regardless of
which side left or right or just a lot
of it's an identity
crisis in themselves an identity issue
in themselves like
they wanna they wanna feel like they
belong to something you know and maybe
they feel like they don't and so
for them it's a lot easier to
just accept and adopt all of these
ideas or values or whatever and
completely
disregard kind of hate
the other side of it because it makes
them a part of something it gives them a
team
you know and we're a country obsessed
with winning
it's not a bad thing like that's why
we're very successful we're
innovators you know where we we lead the
world in a lot of things
um but we struggle in a lot of other
things because of that because we were
so focused on that victory and
being right and like proving our point
and like just that that you know
we see it and we see it in sports of
course
um you know we see it in any kind of
race with another country to be the
first at something and to be the best
and
we see it within our own communities
just that pride you know
we have uh we have a big issue with ego
and uh being wrong
it hurts you know when you feel like man
maybe i was wrong and so no one wants to
ever concede that
it's just to to death they will fight
and argue and you know have a yeah but
answer for every single little thing
even when it's like
seems so ridiculous at what you're
talking about and i just
i always play not always but i often
play devil's advocate
with everybody with someone from a
specific side you know because i can see
the value as you as you mentioned the
value in
people and some of the um
opinions and
reasons as to why they feel like they
feel you know i mean if you
if you're born into a certain situation
typically you adopt a lot of those uh
the values of your environment you know
you mean we're products of our
environment
if i i was born in the middle east i
learned this you know from spending time
over there it was hard for me to
understand how
someone um could maybe be radicalized
like that
but spend time with over there and
see the quality of life or the lack of
quality of life
lack of options and
somebody shows up at your door with a
golden ticket to take care of your
family
and it means sacrificing your life for
what you think is a righteous cause
and you're gonna go to heaven and it's
the right thing to do you might take
some other people with you
but the good outweighs the bad in your
mind
you're gonna do that thing you know or
you're it's easier to understand why
people do that thing and i think that we
we have those issues here
on a social level in the same in the
same way um
and it's uh i don't know it's it's tough
to combat
it's tough to to argue with people like
that or to even have a conversation
often with people like that because
they think you're nuts for even
considering the human nature of somebody
with a different opinion
well if i can shamelessly go ahead i was
just going to say if i can
if i can shamelessly plug the work that
i do nate and the work that we do at
braver angels
um so i'm for anybody who doesn't know
braver angels is the organization for
which i'm a spokesperson it's the
largest
grassroots group in america bipartisan
group working on uh
political depolarization and uh you know
we've got a wide range of programs and
activities that we do that
bring people into debate in a
constructive fashion bring people into
dialogue but one way or another it's all
about at the end of the day
giving folks a window into the actual
sorts of experiences
that people from across the political
divide have
as a means of kind of you know
understanding the roots of their
perspective
right and so brett i know that you're
well familiar with the work of jonathan
height and this idea
that you know our rational minds are
far from being just kind of autonomous
sort of
surveyors of objective truths more like
kind of spokespersons for our emotional
and our
moral intuitions right you sort of
understand that
we understand that by and large our
perspectives on political reality have
something to do with something we've
been through or learned or taken in from
our environment other folks
um there's a lot more room for
compassion i think and understanding and
patience with people
when you get a window into just kind of
what that what that process looks like
for another
another individual you know and it's
it's but it's precisely that type of
thing that's short-circuited
when what we do instead is judge people
according to their political labels or
any other sort of thing
so that we can kind of wipe away the
nuance if you will and just lean into
the thing that says uh first x person x
y
z here is a fascist or communist or you
know
radical this that or the other so that's
the thing that we've got to
disentangle well there's also an issue
of
uh blind spots where
i can almost imagine the position of
somebody who thinks
you'd have to be terrible to be uh
signed up with the republican party if
they belonged to a party
that was making some kind of sense in
other words i have a
the principle that i use is i don't hold
people responsible
for bad decisions if they didn't have
better decisions available to them
and the thing that has struck me for a
long time is that americans are stuck
between
two very bad decisions right
you know it's two different failure
modes and so you know i can't fault you
for being a republican because
what else would you be i mean you could
be a democrat but
uh you know that is to many minds
an equally dangerous if different
uh possibility and i mean
just think about the fact i'm frequently
challenged by people about unity 2020
and their point is
always the only thing is to defeat trump
right that's what must be done i can't
see anything past that doesn't matter
who they nominate doesn't matter who the
vp is i'm voting for him because the
only thing is donald trump
now if that was really the way the
democratic party saw things
wouldn't it have put aside nonsense and
given us
much better candidates in other words i
don't think the democratic party the
machine inside of it believes this
because if it really thought that the
only thing that was necessary
you know the only priority we should
have was defeating donald trump it would
have given us candidates
that couldn't that were beyond question
even if it
compromised them with respect to their
donors or whatever but instead it gave
us
incredibly feeble candidates who are
obviously
not popular with anybody that's a
terrible move if you think
that donald trump is an existential
threat so at some level the people
are signed up for a false narrative the
the parties have set up a
a battle for us that they it's not even
the one they're involved in
so um you know what is the good option i
mean this is really
this is the motivation behind unity 2020
is i'm sick and tired of being left in a
situation where there just simply isn't
a good option
and i'm supposed to be upset at my
fellow americans for choosing
some bad option that happens to be
different than the bad option i've
chosen
enough of that already
nate i've got a i'm i'm curious so just
if i can throw nade a question here
brett
um what's your um
your your family your folks i don't know
if you have brothers and sisters but
your
parents is there a partisan uh tilt in
your family background and if so
what direction does it up does it go in
oh
pretty we're pretty all over the place
which is which is i think a good thing
you know because we uh we have
discussions conversations you know they
always say don't talk about politics
religion at dinner table of course
but um stuff comes up i mean with
everything being politicized how does it
not these days
uh you know and my my parents are
definitely
you know conservative um and we grew up
um you know a lot of conservative values
and grew up
with religion and stuff like that
however i also grew up in
el cerrito california which is right
between berkeley and richmond
um which is arguably probably one of the
most liberal places in the country
so i think i had the good fortune as a
young child to kind of grow up with both
of those things
my parents also like they enjoy you know
they enjoy the arts and music and like
mother plays plays music and my father
likes to travel a lot and like so they
do these things that are
i guess traditionally not not really
conservative things
um and uh they're sort of outside the
box people
and i think that they just you know the
biggest thing for
for them is just the frustration and the
amount of
uh hate that exists at least that we see
you know the amount of hate that is very
powerful
and public these days in the country and
uh and that's frustrating and you know
and they're getting a little bit older
and it's like they want to feel
safe and like they want to you know
they want to be close with their family
and all that
um but they don't these distractions
all of this uh this constant angst and
turmoil
about everything uh isn't a fun isn't a
fun thing so
and i know that's frustrating for them
uh and then my you know my brother and
sister
um they're sort of you know pretty
middle of the road
i'd say you know i'm calling them all
out right now but whatever
um you know they'll be fine i'd say uh
you know they my my brother you know his
wife they probably lean a little bit to
the left and my sister
maybe a little bit to the right it's
hard it's hard to kind of say she used
to be i think a little more conservative
than
even now um and uh and that's
you know we were talking about the
middle earlier brett i mean i call it
the radical
middle you know and that's where i feel
like i kind of sit it's hard for me to
say
which way i mean it depends on the topic
it depends on the situation i think
that's how it should be
it depends on depends on what we're
discussing what is the issue
because i've got varying viewpoints on
that stuff and you know i'm big on
people um taking care of themselves
you know what i mean and figure things
out invest their ability if there's no
way forward and they need assistance
they need help
of course we make that we figure that
out but i don't like this reliance on
somebody else taking care of you
and you know complaining about things
constantly
but then expecting somebody else to fix
the problem or to fix it for you i don't
like that
at the same time i don't like that you
know i don't think it should be every
man for themself
and uh you know when people come from a
tougher situation a tougher background
didn't have a lot of opportunity
maybe didn't have the right guidance um
they need that mentorship and leadership
and
and opportunities that they would not
normally have they need
a chance you know an additional
way forward and then it's up to them at
some point it's up to you to realize
those things that's not really like a
simple thing to sort of
um to lay out
you know but i think that that's that's
my biggest thing is like
is is ownership in ourselves and
say need yeah go ahead well i was uh i
wanted to if it's there i wanted to tie
something to what brett had just uh
said here it's interesting hearing about
the distribution in your
the sentiments in your in your family
and sort of where you come down because
you
yourself seem to be kind of an
amalgamation of the diversity
of you know the points of view that
you're explaining or in your family i'm
just wondering
did was there any for instance can you
think of a family member who has a
picture of ronald reagan
up somewhere in their house or on their
truck or anything like that
we not not a family member no okay the
reason i have but you know folks who
probably do
yeah yeah and the reason the reason i
ask and brett this is this is tying back
to your point about no good options
and why people vote for the parties that
they vote for often times
um when i was campaigning for office um
you know it was very common for me to
see pictures of
the obamas barack michelle their
children
on folks mantle pieces uh in the in the
doors that i would knock on right and
you might say well that's probably
african-americans no it wasn't african
americans but even taking the
obama phenomena and putting it aside
because that was somewhat unique
but i was raised with kennedy nostalgia
in a big big way
you know as a kid i was raised knowing
the story of camelot what camelot was
supposed to be
this new era that kennedy was ushering
in but i know that there's a huge
segment of the country for whom
you know ronald reagan he's he is this
figure in our cultural memory for many
folks and for many other folks he's
something of a demon right which is part
of the issue here
but the cultural memory of ronald reagan
is representing this
reinvigoration this renewal of american
optimism
you know a guy born forth from
traditional values so forth
um the reason i mention all that brett
is because i think that
when you wonder to yourself brett why is
it that the democratic party has seemed
to produce weak and feeble candidates if
it was serious about giving us a a
better option than what was on the table
and you could even say something similar
about the republicans and why the
republican party
selected trump to begin with but it's
certainly in the democratic party
there is this fracturing of the
cultural sort of landscape within the
party which is largely reflective of a
fracturing across the nation where
part of the function of a political
leader the idea of a head of state
president of the united states is that
his role is not
just functional but also ceremonial
political leaders
whether rightly or wrongly in human
history have tended to be looked at as
figures who are supposed to have a
certain cultural significance they're
supposed to
represent something that people can
touch and have a relationship to they
symbolize something
you know again rightly or wrongly they
tend to
be meant to symbolize something some set
of values
uh that that can bind us but it's hard
to do that in a landscape
for any of the individual parties
certainly in the democratic party
where we can't even quite agree on
whether or not
america actually is or is not a racist
country
for instance right we cannot exactly
agree
you know on whether or not the united
states of america
is a country that's founded in pursuit
of freedom or if it's something that's
in hawk to slavery in a
you know on a corrupt capitalist uh
superstructure
um or whatever or what have you there
are all sorts of variations of this
i see the producing of weak political
candidates as
itself being a reflection of the
identity crisis that's at play
in in america in a way to where the safe
bets that get produced or folks who i
mean in this case joe biden
who his great i think appeal
is just the fact that he seems sort of
safe and comfortable whereas any and
everybody else you could have selected
might have seemed to have had some
strong appeal for some segment of the
party
but wouldn't have had a general kind of
popularity because that cultural
connection just isn't there because
we're so fragmented
that's a theory anyway but brett i
wonder what you what you do with that
ball
well first i wanted to respond a little
bit i hear something
very interesting in both your stories
you know nate can't quite figure out
whether he's right or left and i
actually find something totally
beautiful about this
right because i think it's the hallmark
of somebody who's actually doing their
own work
right if you do your own work why would
you
come out with one of these slates or the
other right you'll
your particular values will result in
you landing on a
a unique uh set of
uh of answers and desired objectives
and i hear something similar in your
story john i hear
that you know you're you know you're
enough of a republican that you
headed up the the la county chapter
and yet you campaigned for
obama um so you know i i hear you doing
your own work too and i have to say
as much as i will swear to you that i am
a radical
right um i find myself in the same boat
whereas
to me radical means one thing it means i
believe
radical change is necessary to save us
that's the only reason
i would want us to contemplate it
because it's too damn dangerous
otherwise right you engage in radical
change when you don't have a choice
but in terms of where my values land
it's also eclectic right there are
things about what i believe
that do match better what conservatives
tend to believe and then there are other
things
where i seem much more like a liberal
and so
in any case what i think is missing
is the safe harbor for people
who are of the same mind that we
apparently are
and you know this didn't come up before
we were on screen here together
we discovered this in real time but i
think the point is
lots of people would have this instinct
maybe everybody would
but the um the penalties that come to
you
if you evidence that you're actually
thinking differently about these
individual issues
are such that people are incentivized
out of it and if we
we obviously at unity 2020 have an
objective and it does involve
uh curing the body politic of its
corruption by starting at the top
and you know actually draining the swamp
not draining it to put in a golf course
but draining it because
it shouldn't be a swamp but
to the extent that that's what we do we
also have a secondary objective
i think which is as we have the
discussions necessary to talk about
how we can address our political
situation
we are also providing evidence to people
that there is a way to think
independently
to land on different conclusions than
the people that you're breaking bread
with and to have it not be a catastrophe
and if that can spread that is in and of
itself
a very worthwhile objective
yeah yeah absolutely that's how that's
how
um deals get done in business you know
what i mean
you've got this is our offer this is our
counter and you figure things out you
know and you make a deal
and that's not how that's not how this
is working right now
and that's that's how it probably should
work and that's why things get hung up
for months and sometimes years uh you
know in the senate and congress and
they just don't happen because it's all
one way
all the other way we're pushing this
through we're halting it
and then we're just gonna quit you know
and
it's the government's another government
shutdown coming and blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah
and it's just very frustrating and
mind-numbing as a citizen
i think also as a veteran you know and
you fought for that you fought for
everybody
and it's not that people don't care man
people
are very appreciative of our veteran
community and i love that you know
i get thank you for your service all the
time and i know that people genuinely
care
but what i don't think they understand
is that
we're not just what we're
volunteering to protect is not just
a physical threat from an outside source
you know what i mean
at least for me like i took the oath as
everybody else had to join
to defend the constitution um and the
amendments
in that constitution which can be
changed and
you know everyone should be looked at at
all times once again it's 244 years ago
uh we don't need to live by the the word
and the letter that everything that is
written in there we can we can adjust
with times you know
life changes the world evolves around us
um but that first amendment especially
you know that freedom of speech
freedom of thought freedom of expression
freedom of religion those type of
freedoms
those are very important and those
should be respected
i think by everybody if done in a
in a mature peaceful and respectable
way demonstrated in that way like that
needs to be and if you disagree and
argue
great have that discussion have that you
can call it an argument disagreement
whatever
but yes to to just you know indict
somebody
and call them
all these things and put them in this
box and write them off completely
because they said something or believe
something
and you just you just i mean that's part
of the whole cancer cancer culture you
just
it's not just for celebrities on you
know who tweeted something 10 years ago
it's for everybody
people just get canceled john like what
happened to you at politico you just got
cancelled
you know by that by that woman because
she said
pretty much said what you did you know
after having
a pretty balanced sounds like reasonable
human conversation it just ended so
i i heard something in what you said and
you just blew right by it but it struck
me as so
important and so rarely discussed you
said
that as a soldier you were fighting for
everybody
even the people you disagree with now at
one level that should go without saying
but i think
people have lost touch with this and i
must say
i've never been in the military but i do
feel
um that when i am forced to politics and
it's really
not my instinct i don't like it but
unity 2020 for example
is an attempt to fix things for
everybody
even the people who swear that i'm evil
for even contemplating anything other
than uh you know the main menu of
options
right this isn't about that patriotism
is about the recognition
that um there is something that unites
us
that has nothing to do with the fact
that we do agree over dinner or don't
right it's about a bigger project than
that and i see
very few people are even aware of it
right
um you know and this it's worse when
this happens
at the level of the president because as
you point out john
you know the role of the president is in
some ways a technical role
but it's also a symbolic role right they
have to lead which means they have to
sort of
give voice to um the collective public
will
and when you have you know i mean i'm
harder on the democrats here because in
some sense trump was a break
with the broken republican party in
favor of something that i also find
quite broken
but nonetheless it's not the same
republican party
that i grew up with on the democratic
side though
i mean if we go back to 2016 and you
have
uh you know michael kinsley says a uh
a gaff a political gaffe is when a
politician
accidentally tells the truth and
you know when hillary clinton called
republicans a basket of
deplorables she was basically saying
something in the wrong context
that was something she would have said
in a private context and
should have held her tongue in the
public context because it
revealed exactly what kind of disdain
she had for some large fraction
of the people she claimed to want to
lead and so you know that's
that's the modern democratic party at
this point and
the question i guess is how do we
most americans really do agree over the
basics we don't agree on the priorities
we don't agree to how close we are to
you know a really functional system but
we agree on what a functional system
would be like
generally we know that you know the
hidden tribes report which i mentioned
frequently says that something like 86
percent of us agree on
what america should be
but in this context where we've been
artificially divided by
parties that um are being steered by
their fringes and by
um machine politics a parasite at their
heart
how is it that we can wake people up
to their shared humanity and to
the destruction that is brought to that
by these corrupt parties
right well so i from my vantage point
there are a couple of things that
need to happen um so on a broader sort
of cultural level of course
i tend to speak in terms of saying there
needs to be kind of a way of
understanding the story of america that
makes clear
the fact that as different as all of our
different streams of history are
they sort of join stream in this larger
river of progress that seems to realize
kind of
these higher ideals that inform the
american founding this idea that we're
entitled to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and within that sort of a
mutual
dignity which makes space for
intellectual disagreement
um in pursuit of ultimately bettering
each other towards that realization
but i mean to your point where the
question is how do you actualize that
in in society and i think that on the
one hand
the work that we're doing again at
braver angels and it's not just us
but the work of actually creating the
context in which the american people and
by the way
this live stream is an example of this
uh the work of being
being able to create the context where
we can actually meet each other
uh within a framework of communication
that doesn't predispose us
towards seeing each other through
through a jaded sort of prism
creating the act the space for that
actually building the structures in
which that is possible
is very much necessary because right now
the structures that we lean on cable
news talk radio
the general sort of media culture uh and
also
increasingly uh the traditional
institutions of american life the
universities
there's a way in which this can creep
into the church and
religion and other places where we meet
each other in our lives
um increasingly these traditional sorts
of contexts where we meet each other
uh only allow us to meet each other in
an oppositional
sort of way and so on the one hand we
have to be innovative in creating
the space for the american people to
engage in that way and so again that's
what the work of braver angels is about
that's what
many folks are working on but even at
that uh
for those of us who want to lead in a
reconciliatory direction
we have to be able to speak in these
sorts of unifying terms in the
structures that already exist
and so you know part of what i try to do
and brett i think that in your way you
try to do this
too as a matter of fact you do try to do
this let me not even qualify this
um and nate i see you doing it too man
whether we're on a right leaning or a
left-leaning uh
outlet or on a podcast or anywhere else
to speak in terms of saying look this is
my
subjective perspective but i'm speaking
from a bed of ideas which are aimed at
establishing
the common good right that ultimately we
want to generate opportunity for all
people
ultimately we want to be sensitive to
the differences in people's starting
points so we can understand their
positions
and communicate with one another
effectively
our language cannot shift on the level
of fundamental values
depending on whether or not we're
speaking to a conservative audience or
liberal audience because that just makes
us like the politicians
who can't manage to hold to some truer
kind of ground
in terms of articulating a point of view
that is for all of the american people
as much as is possible so there's a
defensive
game and as much as we need to sort of
hold and build up
ground in the context that we can shape
and control and then there's an
offensive game
where we need to get into the end zone
with the message
uh that can take root even in the
established kinds of
media outlets and so forth and the
difficulty there becomes getting
past the gatekeepers so to speak or you
know finding your way to these places
because
these contexts are sort of designed in a
way to service
the polarized partisan establishments
but nevertheless
there's a hunger in america for this
type of for for this philosophy of civic
engagement
and that makes me think that there are
ways to get this ball into the end zone
part pardon the the corny football
analogies nate
you're good you're good i know you hear
them all the time no it's all good yeah
i'm with you on that you know i i just
it's going to take a great deal of uh
humility
which we we lack quite a bit uh as a
nation i think
by and large at this point where
it's like we're not in a place
seemingly that that we are seeking
the individual that's best suited
to be the figure i don't like to say run
the country
but to be the figurehead or the
representative of this country
we are are more interested in the one
that looks after my own personal
interests
who will who agrees with me
and i pick them it's not about values
it's not about personality
really like you mean people will you
know they
they act like because that person is
their representative for their party
that they are
you know on board with uh with joe biden
or donald trump
but you can see it and feel it in a lot
of their heart of hearts like they don't
like the person they don't like the
choice they don't really think
that that person is the right leader
um but you know it's become this
um cultic thing you know where
i mean the amount of like trump flags
for instance that i see in the lack of
american flags that i see
really disturb me it really frustrates
me
matt is like that's patriot that's like
a patriotic thing now to do that you
know
and as i can as far as conservatives uh
see it it's it's patriotic to have that
trump flag in your
yard because he's the president damn it
and you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna worship
him i mean
not that you should be worshiping the
american flag either but it's just
uh i i remember growing up and only
seeing that you know
that was a popular thing most people in
our country
saw that as a beacon of hope most people
around the world see that a speaking of
hope
and now it is like you know it is such a
divisive
object and uh it just
yeah it it really that really
is something that that shot of a that
shot of humility
um that everybody's gonna have to take
in order for this to actually work
for this dramatic change this revolution
to occur which is necessary is for
people to
truly find who are the individuals who
are the
people that would best represent all of
us listen to all of us
take into account all of our concerns
and try to find uh
try to find what's best for everybody
i mean and that's it's not an easy thing
to do but
where it stands right now it's like
these candidates
they're representing half the country
they're not representing the nation
they're not representing the american
people
they're representing half of the
american people they're fighting for
half the american people they just hope
that more of their half shows up to the
booths
on november 4th or november 3rd
whichever day it is i think it's
november 3rd
then the other sides 50 you know
hopefully two out of three of mine show
up and only half of their show up so we
win
because then i'm good to represent my
team and i don't really care about the
other team
i just want to represent to represent my
team well the problem though
and it's it's a hard thing to say but
i'm
driven to say it a little bit in
response to um
what john said about biden being seeming
like the safe choice
i don't think he does seem like the safe
choice in fact i think he seems like a
very perilous choice but he does seem
safe with respect
to what the dnc represents
and so i would just point out that
there's something absurd
about the fact that the democrats claim
to want to win and to have to win for
the good of the nation
there were candidates that did capture
the imagination
that did spark people's passion and they
were all
sidelined in favor of a candidate
that doesn't inspire anyone even at his
best he didn't inspire
but in his hasn't lived in the real
world in 50 years
hasn't lived in the real world in 50
years doesn't
have any unique ideas to speak of i
can't name
one um it has demonstrated through
his choice of a running mate now that
really
this is all about the dnc view of the
world
and so and i'd also just point out in
passing a couple of other things
he announced his running mate in text
now i've noticed as others have that
there is a difference
in how cogent he seems when he's on
camera
even when it's scripted and when he's
for example tweeting
or delivering a note that's very ominous
the idea that we would elect somebody
who at this point you know once upon a
time
he could deliver a pretty fair speech he
doesn't appear to be capable of it
we're talking about governing a nuclear
nation and leading it in a time
of tremendous polarization it's
manifestly not safe to elect a person
that compromised but nonetheless
we're going to do it and the reason well
i don't know that we're going to do it
but we're going
the democrats would have us do it and
the reason that they have chosen the
candidate that inspires
no one over candidates that inspired
many
was that those candidates that inspired
people did so
because they actually represented a kind
of
change and the fact is i've said for a
long time that the dnc's purpose
is to prevent meaningful change we can
have anything else we want but we can't
have meaningful
change and so that's what joe biden
represents he represents
no meaningful change and the reason that
the dnc does not want meaningful change
is because it represents established
interests who are threatened by change
and they're not threatened by the status
quo and at some level it's that simple
and you can see how this plays out in
the fact that
not only did they nominate
uh or did they put kamala harris on the
ticket in the vp spot
but they denied andrew yang a spot to
speak
at the convention when he clearly did
inspire a great many of us
why would they do that because he
represents an actual
uh path to change and so that's
unacceptable to them and they're going
to snub him
once again so at some level i think
people need to wake up to the fact that
just as the republican party is not the
one that we grew up with
the democratic party is not the one we
grew up with either it has
effectively got a parasitic infection
it's like it has rabies
and you know to do its bidding is to do
the bidding of the disease not the
bidding of the people it once
represented
well brett can i can i say something um
that might sort of seem in a sense to be
in defense of
uh joe biden but i don't think it
necessarily contradicts anything that
you
that you said i mean you're welcome to
contradict anything i've said this
is about an honest discussion so the
truth is i don't
i don't disagree with the idea that
political parties and political
institutions favor candidates that allow
them to maintain the status quo and i
think you can make a very strong
argument
that joe biden uh does that uh for the
dnc so i i'm
it's not to quibble with that but let me
explain what i mean when i
refer to him as this in a sense the safe
choice it's not that he's
inspiring to to i think very many people
in the democratic coalition
but there's a reason why he's
comfortable in a meaningful way when we
think about
the nominee of a presidential party and
a potential president
as being sort of a cultural figure and a
cultural
representative here joe biden is the one
candidate
in that field that was made up of a lot
of folks who
were you know in many cases you know
younger
sharper more of their wits left to him
and even i mean bernie sanders is joe's
age but had
more of his wits left to him i think in
terms of his delivery just
had more fire and so forth here's the
thing about joe biden
and the democratic primary the
democratic primary is ultimately driven
out of all the constituencies in the
party
by the african-american voting bloc by
and large
not just in terms of you know the
concentration of the black vote in
certain key states but the way in which
uh the politics of communities of color
and within that african-american
the african-american community in
particular has begun to drive sort of
has long
sort of driven more and more over time
at least
the social tone of politics within the
party
joel biden is not a black man cory
booker is kamala harris is so on and so
forth
um but neither kamala harris nor cory
booker had a sort of appeal to the
broader constituencies of the party
which have to include the white working
class and so forth and
people who are longing for a sort of
stability that comes with season and
experience that joe biden
was able to provide in his background
with his resume given his length of time
in office and yet
joe biden has something like a native
appeal to the black community because
one thing that
just about any and all supporters of
barack obama
uh in the competing community know and
feel and believe
is that joe biden really did seem at
least to have a personal loyalty
uh to barack obama to the first
african-american president who wasn't
just
incidentally black but was a person who
people honestly loved
you know people not just in the black
community certainly
but people in the black community to be
sure honestly
loved and trusted barack obama even if
they were disappointed
with so much in the way of his actual
material output for the country
those things in a way are divorcible and
so
you look at joe biden and what you have
is a person who has some social and
cultural credibility
with the african-american uh community
and the base and that
that in the key base constituency in the
party while also being
a familiar and a relatable sort of
figure to white working class democrats
who
folks wanted to win back from donald
trump and to a degree
you know a wider range of folks in the
community and by the way
joe biden's relationships in the black
community don't just
start with barack obama it goes decades
before that
his relationship with jim clyburn the
folks in baltimore folks in southern
states folks in different parts of the
community of color over the course of
time through his relationships in
congress and the senate and so forth but
just
joe biden being a traditional retail
sort of politician
he knows people people have a
familiarity with them so that's what i
mean when i say joe biden is the safe
choice
you wouldn't want to reduce his
significance all the way down to him
merely being an institutional
puppet he is a life and blood human
being who has some social presence
where it mattered most right and so i
think to
comprehensively understand who joe biden
is in this context
you have to understand him in part at
least in that way
well i i appreciate the analysis and
there's a good bit of it that i
uh i think is right but the there's also
just an irony to it
and the irony is that the status quo
um reproduces patterns of inequity
through time that's what it does and so
to the extent that the black community
has actually
gotten the short end of the stick which
i believe it has
that short end of the stick process is
continued
by the dnc not because the dnc is
anti-black but because the dnc is status
quo
and the status quo leaves people in
circumstances in which oh
you're unlucky you're born into this zip
code that means you're going to face all
kinds of disadvantages that reduce
the likelihood that you will have the
tools to make use of the market to get
ahead
right so i guess my point is
symbolically speaking
he may be a a safe seeming choice
for black voters but what he represents
is anything but
safe for black voters and um
so in any case oh go ahead
no no just to say that that's why i say
none of that analysis i think runs the
foul of what you're saying
right um from the standard from the
vantage point of understanding
how some people are thinking and how
they relate to our political candidates
you know
it's important to have that larger
social frame right and there's a
parallel thing to be said about
donald donald trump which we could go
into if we wanted but the point is it is
totally possible
for a politician to be somebody who who
seems to genuinely connect
with his constituency and maybe he
really does you know i'm just
to be charitable right and yet still
operate in service
to a structural you know mechanical
established status quo
that continues uh to drain opportunity
uh from the very constituent groups from
the very people that that politician
professes to serve
those two things can absolutely be true
at the same time and yet understanding
that possibility
is still perhaps important for warding
ourselves away from the temptation
to totally demonize some of these folks
even some of these
political leaders because it can be the
case of course that again person can be
in service to something that is corrupt
and not working
and still have some good intentions at
play or some real social connections
that
that account for who they are and why
they are where they are
so moral reality becomes complicated
but the the need to recognize the way in
which the system
turns on those it serves is still
something we can look at with very sober
eyes well i
i quite agree with that and you know i
think i have taken great pains not to
demonize joe biden
as a person um you know to the extent
that i'm dehumanizing something it's the
dnc which isn't a human
so i think it's fair um but
you know my point would be look at some
level
as long as you play this game at the
level
of symbolism then you will be owned by
things like the dnc which will play the
symbolic game pretty well and they'll
feed you something that feels
safe and familiar and all the while
they're robbing you
out the back door and the point about
unity 2020 is that it is an alternative
that is not
symbolism first in fact it's not
symbolism at all
it is a gamble on the idea that if you
simply gave people who were above
politics
and understood values on both sides of
the aisle
if you gave them sufficient power by
speeding them past the corrupting
process
and into a position where they could
actually lead
that that would actually do a tremendous
amount for communities like the black
community
like the american indian community like
all people who are
facing economic and other kinds of
oppression just by virtue of the fact
that they would be inclined to do the
right
thing and the right thing will correct
those problems automatically
not fully right we can't expect
perfection but it will at least move us
in the right direction so
i'm hoping that people will tune into
this conversation and others
and they will realize that it is the
symbolism that has allowed things to get
so bad because symbolism is cheap
right and that the substance can be
fixed but it does involve us
departing the narrative in which we have
no choice but to vote
for the standard options
yeah right well yeah i mean and
this is why i emphasize up top um
nate my my uh enthusiasm for unity 2020
being born from the fact that
on the one hand you know yes there's the
strategic uh
there's what we can argue at least is
the strategic need to
change not just you know who the
occupant of the white house might be
it's
it's it's beyond that getting folks in
office and i think this applies on every
level of government right
um who are willing to govern for the
common good and conceptualize their role
in that way yet uh on the other hand i
feel that
you know and even for folks brett who
may not be supporting unity 2020 at this
moment but who are
engaged in this conversation to say look
one way or the other
our politics and who we elect are going
to be a reflection
of the very spirit of the sorts of
conversations that we're having
with each other are we demonizing each
other and shutting each other out
are we open to one another's experience
and perspectives and looking to create
some wisdom
that is greater than the sum of its
parts right and so i see unity 2020
as growing out of this this sort of
movement in this direction where this
big heterodox kind of
space i mean everything from the
intellectual dark web to the work that
braver angels and folks in the
depolarization
movement are doing to this plurality of
americans who are leaving the political
parties to folks who are still in the
parties but who are represented in the
research shown by
more in common the hidden tribe support
that you mentioned i was on a call
tim dixon who led a lot of that research
the other day
we see these sentiments that are seeking
to really
humanize our fellow americans looking
for a home
looking for a way to join stream in
search of a better nation in search
of a better country and a better future
right for our children
everybody else but right now we're
locked into
structural and cultural patterns and
status quos
which continue to take more and more
from us with each election cycle every
time we choose
the lesser of two evils not just in
terms of who we vote for
but in terms of how we are willing to
settle uh
and compromise ourselves in terms of how
we treat each other
in the process of even being able to
achieve that lesser of two evils right
uh and so you know it is rebalancing our
internal
instincts our internal dispositions
towards each other
which i think is the route from which it
truly sort of
unified america can spring and we'll get
better politics and better politicians
from that
beautifully said we're not going to
realize great change if nothing great
changes
if
we're on the hamster or the hamster
wheel right now and it's just
we're not going anywhere we might be
moving fast but we're not going anywhere
yeah it's not going to change unless
something dramatic happens it's just
that's how life is you know what i mean
if you don't like something about
yourself
you keep making the same mistakes you
keep doing it and you want to change it
you've got to do something drastic
you've got to make a great change in
yourself
you know you've got it's got to be your
habits and
how you interact with the world every
day you've got to be focused on that
thing
really hard to do that's the only way
that those things change
um and if we don't even if we just don't
try if we just accept that this is the
way that it is
it's always going to be like this and
there's nothing that we can do
then if this is this is the way it's
going to be
and there is nothing that we can do if
that's what we accept
um i don't accept that i think a lot of
people feel the same way
it's just it's not simple i mean how do
we make this happen
you know it's got to be a huge team
effort
as brett has said it's got to be a
ground swell
from people from individuals everybody's
got to
share this message be on board for this
fight for this and
that is the only way we get out of our
own way
is by doing something dramatic yeah
that's yeah by the way mate you've got a
good president's chin i'd say very
president
is that why you're on here man is brett
we have our dark horse candidate uh on
the line with us
are we are we gearing in for a surprise
announcement or maybe maybe next
elections
well i i should tell you so first of all
i want to uh react a little bit
um to what nate has said you're right
something dramatic has to happen or
we will have the illusion of moving very
fast and
and the reality of getting nowhere it's
not going to get
easier or safer so to the extent that it
does not feel easy or safe
that's an argument for doing it now
rather than later and
i think the other thing that we're
drawing to a close of this first hour
here and
the what i'm getting from this is
this conversation flawed sprawling as it
may be
is vastly better it feels better
it has more weight to it than the
polarized conversation that we're being
bombarded by
all the time in normal venues
so the real point is look if you can see
that this is better
and you can see that we are trying to do
something to deviate our course
enough that we just don't get more and
more opportunities to
uh to go after each other then
join us and it doesn't mean that you're
committing yourself
to anything the fact is we're in the
nomination process we're
putting forward names and it's very
heartening actually to see these names
come in and see how many
really good people that you would love
to see elected to office
you know submitted as nominations and
how many people are thinking carefully
about this enough to submit these
these nominations for us to um to
advance them
so if that feels better to you than
what's going on in the world
then join us and what you're going to
find is a bunch of
really interesting people who aren't
alike in many regards but are aligned
over the shared sense that we must do
something
and that our differences as big as they
are are small
relative to that which unifies us so
um maybe that's where we should oh go
ahead john
oh no i was just uh saying amen and
hallelujah that's all
amen and hallelujah is good all right so
i think what we should do um i loved uh
both of the
final statements that you you gave i
don't think there's any reason to
to go further with that i would like to
take a break now
to look at some of the feedback we got
on our initial
questions and then to re-gather in
15 minutes for some discussion in which
we will try to interact with the
audience who has assembled
and get a sense for what they're
thinking how does that sound
sounds good to me all right great
so um stay put if you're there
especially if you're logged into
democracy ai if you weren't lucky enough
to be in the
first thousand people who got to log
into
uh democracy ai you can find the
discussion going on
at chooseunity hashtag chooseunity on
twitter
noah is there anything you need to tell
us before we uh take our break
hey uh so there is not anything i need
to tell you we still have a
few spots open i'm excited to share what
everyone has
shared uh so far and uh we'll get to it
in just about 15 minutes
great so it sounds like there are a few
spots grab them quick because they won't
last long and we will see you in
about 15 minutes until then be well
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good
[Music]
did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
inward or outward all right welcome back
folks to our
second campfire for unity 2020.
um much of this break that we have just
spent
uh we were looking at some very
interesting data that noah who is the
disembodied voice
behind the scenes was showing us from
democracy ai
so i will confess democracy ai is a very
powerful tool that allows us to interact
with you and to learn
what you're thinking we are very much
learning on the fly
how to leverage it so in any case please
bear with us as we figure out how to
apply it
i think the first thing to do is to look
at some of the answers that we got to
the initial questions that we
posed to you both the three before the
stream and the
uh one at the beginning of the stream so
noah can you show us
some of that data
yes uh you should hopefully in just a
second see
on your screen our poll results
um the question the first question we
want to focus on here
is uh we asked people before unity 2020
which of the following categories most
represented your political views
uh we we had five different categories
one being none of these options but
the other two were vote trump we need to
drain the swamp uh trump is a problem
vote blue no matter who
i'm gonna reluctantly vote democrat we
need to but we need to tear this whole
system down
and i'll reluctantly vote for trump
there's a left-wing threat to our nation
it needs to be stopped um
really quickly to take you through these
numbers that you should now see on your
screen
uh these percentages are the percentage
of people
likely to agree with each one of these
answers can you scroll
up zach so that we can see they're not
blocked by the
the image of us working oh is it noah
who needs to scroll up
all right tell me when tell me when
we're good i'm scrolling
you know up other way other way
there you go all right all right great
so um what you'll see here is a
percentage likely to agree
with each one of uh each one of these
options actually this is a poll
excuse me these are a hard number of
who's gonna agree
um and then we also asked people when
they were on boarded uh
if they were gonna before unity 2020
where they were planning to vote for
trump
or vote for biden so roughly brett uh
take it away and talk through this but
what you can see is these numbers should
check out we've got a we've got a mix of
people
um and we've got a lot of a lot of
republican
a lot and a lot of democrats and um
and i think probably the the thing to
call out here is that you you've got a
variety of opinions
yep um so i i think actually some of
this will be borne out if we go into the
other
questions uh so can we go move on to the
next set of questions
absolutely let me uh let me get us there
um because our our next set so here
people can see the interface and when we
get to see on our end
um so the next thing that we asked are
not the next thing but the next thing we
want to call out was do you feel like
there's a real and present danger to
america
and the answer right here uh 95 of the
participants
uh said yes um so what we did is
ask in an open-ended question how would
you describe
that danger or lack of danger to a
friend now i'm gonna go ahead and hit
analyze here
and what you'll see are some of the
answers that we have and hopefully
you're able to see that on your screen
um and uh this is the percentage of
people likely to agree
with each answer and i can also sort
this so what let's let's do this brad
let's take
the answers most likely for trump voters
to agree with
and um maybe you want to kind of talk
through these first top two answers here
and
get people's feelings about that and so
these are just to be clear these are
answers that were submitted
by people uh logged into this tool
and then these were the top vote getters
so people could submit an answer and
then other people voted them sort of
reddit style
uh to to reach the top is that right
um so uh the the first part of that is
right what i want to say is it's not
reddit style we use um algorithms uh
to figure out what what's called uh
matrix completion
um and synthetic voting uh so there's
some artificial intelligence and machine
learning behind all of this
uh so what that means is that people
don't need to vote on every single
answer for us to have statistically
relevant results
instead by voting on answers within a
two to three minute time period
as uh as many as you you feel
comfortable voting on
we're able to get this percentage likely
to agree
um the more people the more confident we
are in that score
i see so the first answer uh
is the republic is in danger and our
country is facing a potential
takeover or takedown of all we hold to
be
american and this was this 69
of respondents resonated 78 percent of
trump voters
resonated and 64 percent of biden voters
resonated
so uh an overarching fear
that something is going to take over and
take down
the core values of the country
all right second one there is a real
chance
that one of these two things will happen
people will lose confidence in
government
to the extent that law and order breaks
down or conversely the powers that be
will use the social unrest to further
their own executive authority
so either things come apart or they
become
authoritarian in a
bureaucratic sense that the opportunity
of law and order breaking down will be
utilized
by the powers that be resonated by
resonated for 70 percent of respondents
trump voters resonated somewhat more 77
percent
and biden voters 70. so something about
the ai is causing those numbers not to
be
um compatible in an obvious way but
um that's the percentage agreement so
what one way to
one way you could interpret this is um
yeah
mostly trump voters agreed a lot with
this right
but but biden voters also agreed with
these statements what i think i'd point
out here is on the right hand column
people who would vote for biden are are
many of them would agree with the same
things that trump voters would agree
with
um and then this all another thing if we
add up these numbers here
50 50 there's 103 people here but almost
200 people voting
so about half of your audience would not
vote for trump or
vote for biden right awesome variety of
reasons now if we sort this
for what the biden voters agree with you
can see the same plays out we're going
to have some different answers here
uh but again there's a lot of alignment
okay so it's interesting the trump and
biden voters the would-be trump and
biden voters
are resonating with the same uh
statements at slightly different rates
should we go two more answers and by the
way john and nate
you are welcome to react to what you're
seeing
and to propose things that you would
like
the audience to be queried about in real
time so
anything yet not at this moment sir
okay so um
third answer we have two parties that
act like street gangs
putting their party's interest before
that of the people loyalty to move
loyalty to money and interest first
endless pointless wars
as long as we keep settling for these
candidates the polarization continues
well that's interesting that uh mirrors
many of the things that we were saying
in our
first hour of discussion i think this is
um
and again the um looks like above 70
percent
resonance across the board and the
fourth one you got to scroll up a little
bit for me to see it completely
political polarization is preventing
everyday folks from engaging in
conversation
they're so far wedged into their
political corners silos and echo
chambers
that they're all convinced the other
party is to blame
or that trump alone is the problem
yep and again 70 or above across the
board
so what i get out of this is
this is a little bit what the scales
falling from the eyes
sounds like that there's something about
people who are still caught up in some
narrative
about um you know trump is the only
thing that we must focus on
or the converse is that uh
you know the marxists have taken over
the democratic party or something along
those lines
and for those of us who are beginning to
understand that we are being played
this is the recognition these are the
the ways that that recognition manifests
in the mind
are these particular fears about the
danger that this is
putting us in does this resonate for you
guys to see
the conversations you're having that's
exactly it you know i i i
i'm also aware that you know most the
people who are probably polling
feel similarly to us of course um
which is great uh you know i i think a
lot of people
would that are probably fall into those
categories
um as far as you know the echo chambers
and whatnot
wouldn't want to see this or
you know probably wouldn't agree with it
they wouldn't admit and that comes back
to that humility conversation that
wouldn't want to uh
uh recognize that in themselves that
they're probably that
and they would have a yeah but you know
but how do you not see that
trump is destroying this country or how
do you not see
the threat of of um yeah
a uh you know a socialized america or
whatever you want to call it
and uh i mean i get that i understand
that what they're saying i hear you
but uh yeah it just it's exactly that
it's it's
it's it is a huge harm to us it's a huge
danger
and i think i think a lot of people do
recognize it yeah i think people
that even fall in those categories
probably recognize it but to them
they don't see any way out they see that
it is what it is we cannot change it
so for me it's the lesser of two evils
in this situation and that's that's also
dangerous i i don't
i don't i'm not inspired unless i'm
inspired you know what i mean and i'm
not going to
attach myself to something if i don't
believe it just because the other way
or the other side is maybe maybe more
dangerous
i need to believe it i need to be all in
and uh
you know i'll i'll fight for what i
believe in uh and hopefully bring some
people along with me enough to
uh you know help us all change the same
together
i dig it and i also have uh i have a
query for the uh
for for the audience um i think my my
question would be
and this is particularly for folks who i
think sort of
you know maybe sort of strongly
identifies democrats or republicans or
biden voters and trump voters may be
more pertinent pertinently but
do you see values
and or concerns on the other side of the
aisle
that you agree with or relate to
even if you disagree or strongly
disagree
um with the overall politics of the
other side
does that make sense brett or should i
should i try and articulate that in a
shorter kind of way no i got it i think
i'm i'm guessing noah got it enough to
to pose it
yep restate it for in one moment as i
type it
uh because but i think that's a great
question do you see values
and or concerns on the other side of the
aisle that you agree or relate to
even if you strongly disagree with can
we say
with the party with the party in general
yes
yeah i think that that gets it all right
i'm gonna ask this and you'll have an
answer in about two minutes and 10
seconds you can see that
i'm here because we're gonna ask uh
you're gonna get uh
you know a couple hundred people's
answers so let's see this in action you
know guys i was
i was thinking about this on the break
um and
when it comes to leadership in the
military and probably
a lot of uh corporation big business
you know when we have an elected
official a president a ceo
whatever you call it um
to me the the more impactful ones
they don't necessarily have these
big grand uh save the world ideas
the the ones that are successful hire a
really good team
have a really good team around them of
differing opinions
and when they get in that war room when
they get into these the board room or
whatever
um they're the ones that you know
ultimately makes that final decision
when they hear everybody out and
everybody else's different ideas and
thoughts how are we going to grow our
business how are we going to fix what's
broken how are we going to do this how
we're going to do that
and you know the best military leaders i
ever had were the ones
that literally listened to everybody it
didn't matter if it was we call it we
call them private snuffy mcgee
you know it didn't matter if that was it
was that guy that just
everyone was like oh geez here he goes
again hey listen to him because once in
a while
that guy has the most obvious uh
quick fix and right probably correct
answer that no one was thinking of
because everyone was so
far in the weeds on like this is the way
we do things and this is how it's got to
be and blah blah blah
that you know they don't see the forest
for the trees and uh
that's strongly lacking in political
leadership
i don't see that it's like when you get
into these and it's tough because i
understand
when it comes to debates you have to
have ideas
you have to have your theories they
probably have to be
pretty pretty strong
pretty radical maybe and pretty new to
get people
excited and get people interested and
build that following
you know and so you can get elected
because it's all about winning you know
and then once
once you get elected it's like
immediately you're starting to think
about re-election
and preparing for that and that's just
that's the game
um but the best the best leaders i've
ever encountered both in sports in the
military ones that yes they made
decisions they were just decisive they
delegated
they did uh what they needed to do and
everyone looked up to them and felt
like this person's got it like i i trust
them i will follow them
but they were better listeners than
anything else you know and they
they took it took into took to heart
what everybody said
um and sometimes they just said i just
don't think that's a good idea and
sometimes they said you know what i
hadn't thought about
that i normally wouldn't do it that way
but um
we should try this maybe we should maybe
implement this a little bit and that's
something in the
political system as someone who's not a
super political guy
it's probably what turns me off about it
more than anything it's just that
just that there you know that it's about
it's about the individual
um it's not about what's best for the
company
i agree with that uh i agree with that
entirely um there's a
you know there's there's a biblical
reference there's a wis there's wisdom
and a multitude of counselors
right and uh brett i actually feel like
this is somewhat
implicit in in the unity proposal
because the way in which it
conceptualizes the relationship
between the candidates is that it is
sort of highly
consultative at least between the two of
them but i
i imagine that if we want to build a
culture out that
shifts the tone and tenor of politics
that it has to be broadly
collaborative right and so this is why
loosening
of the you know of of our being wrapped
around the partisan axles
axles is also so necessary right because
you know that type of
knee-jerk sort of built-in resistance to
other points of view
there's a word for that it's called
bigotry right and in addition to it
being corrosive to relationships
it therefore also is is is a strong
impediment
to um to coordination to learning
and so um you know um yeah nate
wise words but hard to swallow in a
society where everybody is so
bound and determined to sound smart and
be right that we can't sort of create
the space for
listening and receiving the wisdom of
folks who we may
feel are i don't know less qualified or
otherwise perhaps
in the way of all the right answers that
we have to share
so i mean sorry go ahead no i was gonna
say
you know it's this this the world we're
in right now um
beyond the political spectrum you know i
go outside
and i live in la and you live in l.a
john too and you so you understand it
you see it
this the amount of the amount of
concrete and technology and
and just the digital world you know and
access to everything right now right now
right now
uh and just this lack of connection to
to
the when i say the real world the
environment
and people as as people as as as human
beings
you know as not as a emojis or
you know a screen screen handle or
whatever you want to call it
like it is killing us we are killing
each other by living this way
you know and it's it is crept it's crept
into
every facet of life and talk about
politics i mean this was
that was probably 2016 was probably the
first uh at least in my recollection
the first election that was
seemed almost purely digital you know
what i mean i i understand we had
debates and then this year they're going
to be i don't know how they're going to
do them
what's the point exactly as far as
virtual this and that but
you know with covet it's exacerbated
even more everything is digital now
and it's just that there's just no
connection to
to reality and to you know to the world
that i think as it was
intended uh and it does make things
simpler and easier for people in some
ways
but also greatly complicates and makes
things incredibly difficult
uh when it comes to uh
you know i guess just the
the the connection of one another you
know
and truly empathizing and truly feeling
um like
we are really a part of something it's
part of something genuine
and uh and making a difference and
feeling like we matter in this world
that's just
getting bigger and bigger and faster and
you know we're all trying to play
catch-up in so
it's kind of a daunting statement there
um but uh
you know that's part of that dramatic
shift it's not just in politics i think
it's
in the way that we live our lives right
well there's a an aspect of this
which is you know those questions
reflect
the sense that we are hurtling towards
something
you know it's like we're on a train and
it's dawning on us that there's
nobody banning the the engine and that
we're hurtling towards a
you know the end of the line somehow and
so people are waking up which is very
frightening
but it's also liberating to discover
that there are other people awake and
that you don't have to have that
mind-numbing conversation but it does
raise a question for me i think many of
the people
who are uh who have ears to hear this
conversation are having that
sense that we are headed towards
something frightening
but the conversation we don't typically
have is one about the time scale
and so i don't know how to phrase the
question
but maybe we can smith it together what
i want to know
is people keep talking to me about
oh unity2020 that's a cool idea but how
about 2024
you know after we deal with the real
problem and my sense is
i just wouldn't bet on us getting to
2024
intact in other words there'll be
something but
um so i guess the question that i want
to
want the answer to is what percentage of
the audience has the sense
that um if we miss
in 2020 that we should try again in 2024
that the opportunity will be there and
what percentage
um believes that the trajectory we're on
is so dangerous on
such a short time scale that uh that's
unlikely
to work awesome
i will work on formulating that question
uh before i do
uh i did want to point out we we asked
the question
of uh of whether there's things we can
reach across the aisle and i will admit
i did not formulate the question quite
right because the answer was
yes but i think the question you really
wanted the answer to is
can you describe the values that reach
across the aisle
um on your screen you should see of
a bunch of different answers i've
sorted by all uh so that's the priority
here is the the most agreed to
answers and then you can see that
there's a lot of agreement between trump
and biden voters
do want to point out of course people
who watch this show
are not a representative sample of
americans
but the people who are watching this
show have a lot of agreement around the
issues that you see on the left hand
side of this screen
but what that does signify is that at
the very least
we can see that there is this
cross-section of trump voters inviting
voters and you know it's natural
uh to think that if they're going to
converge anywhere in the
in podcast land you know the darkhorse
podcast is a pretty
likely stopping point right but but
still
um that's not that that's not even uh
that's not disqualifier of the
significance of the fact that there
clearly are
points at which uh at least you know a
faction of folks on either side of this
major uh split in america in american
politics
do see areas of convergence and i'm
willing to bet
actually in fact i'd stake everything on
the idea that
that space in which we converge on the
levels of some more fundamental values
and objectives
uh is much bigger than people people
realize and
again you know we can go back to the
hidden tribes report
but you can almost just take it down to
the very basic fact that you know we're
all
human beings who share um we share a
country
broadly speaking we share a history of
course they're radically different
you know streams in that that history
different avenues of experience um but
you know there is a way in which i think
it would be hard for any of us to
conceive
of a fulfilling and happy
life and a fulfilling and happy society
which was not also
maximizing the goods of liberty the
goods
of justice or material goods like
education
economic opportunity and i think you
would also be hard-pressed to find
americans who don't have a basic sense
of the fact that to safeguard those
goods
and those values we have to treat each
other and interact with each other
in a certain way and so you know it
really takes a lot of work to pull us
away from that basic consensus
but the polarizing establishments are
doing a lot of work so
we're in the situation we're in but that
that compels me to be hopeful uh in the
final analysis
the time frame question not not the
standing uh brett because i
i see the urgency there um but i do
think
that just to speak to that really
quickly you don't mind
my general sense is always that we need
to do as much as we can today without
also
um foregoing the need to plan for
tomorrow
right and to the extent to which we can
maximize
both of those things you know i see
success for unity 2020 obviously you
know
the highest marker of success would be
you you field up you field a ticket
that's able to
to inspire the american people towards
shifting the direction of our
presidential politics that it changes
things
you know on the top level and that would
be amazing and i think that we shouldn't
give up hope at the idea that that scale
of change is possible while also
committing to the fact that even if that
was accomplished the most important
shift
on a foundational level takes place in
our relationships between one another
and so i go back to the work of braver
angels i go back to the
to the project of building out civic
structures in civil society
that give us space to interact with each
other and collaborate with each other
digitally physically et cetera in
politics and the grassroots on the
college campuses
uh in in the halls of government um
that work uh can be successful uh
regardless of who wins the presidential
election even as we pursue
change at the highest level um all of
these things
i think are a part of this of this
larger wave of change
that i do think is going to prove itself
to be successful
as we adapt to the challenges at hand um
you know this year and beyond
100 agree that basically yes
we have a um a plan
for a rapid fix or a fix that would
begin rapidly
but whether or not that plan succeeds
that
waking people up to what we are losing
in this polarization such that they are
prepared
irrespective of what comes is is work
that needs to be done
so um i guess maybe part of the reason
that it's formulated the way it is
is that one doesn't have to choose it's
the right direction irrespective of
which mechanism or both mechanisms
function
so go ahead and spot data for john
uh as he talked about the ways where the
same but now i've switched over to
your uh polling question brett so i i
tried to phrase these as best as
possible but you should see some results
on screen um
so 158 people answered this question
which is should give us some confidence
that this represents unity 2020
um can you see the the answers
yep
okay um can we get to you showed some
uh data about who is interested
in unity 2020 uh during the break here i
thought it was very
interesting um yeah well actually uh one
of the things uh that that we were
exploring i think everybody here has
spoken to
the moment that brought them to unity
2020
um so the question that we asked was to
explain an experience that kind of got
you
here um and i'm just scrolling through
and searching for that
um and uh and i'm gonna bring that up in
a second and talk you through
through that i believe that's right up
here um
great so the question we asked is uh can
you describe the moment or experience
that most
piqued your interest in the ideas of
unity 2020
that unity 2020 represents um and now we
didn't ask people to
since this is a personal experience what
we then ask people to do
is is to categorize how they would see
that experience
so we can click in here on on the screen
and say
um say this and i thought brett this was
really cool um
you may be making new voters uh
one of the answers verbatim that people
said is what brought them to 2020 is
discussion
on joe rogan podcast i'm considering
voting for the first time in my life
i've never felt like it was more
important that i stand up and speak
so i got to tell you this gives me
chills a little bit
and it also is reflected in the data
that we collected
on our 1500
volunteers who took a survey as they
came through the door
and a number of things were in that one
was that the
source populations were about evenly
divided between people who
would have supported trump and people
who would have supported biden
with a slightly larger number coming
from the trump side
but a large number something like a
quarter if i'm recalling correctly
were drawn from people who were not
planning to vote
otherwise and so one of the things that
has been true about our
political system is that it drives
people away and it doesn't care
right if it alienates people out but it
doesn't change who wins
the power that is won is the same
the legitimacy of that power is reduced
when people are driven away from voting
but the amount of power that's divided
and peddled
is the same and so the idea that unity
2020 is actually bringing a significant
number of voters
back into the fold because again they
see
something worth their consideration
is extremely heartening and so for all
of the people who say
you know you can't do this you'll spoil
the election a it appears that that's
not the case
based on the split between the different
types of voters who are arriving
right very evenly split but the new
voters
that are being brought back are a
dividend on this plan
that i must say i wouldn't have dared
hope for at this level
to the extent that anything re-energizes
people and brings them back
into the active role of citizens
i think it's a very good thing and it
really has has spurred us on
so here we see some poll results
this is data that just supports what you
said we asked a thousand
a thousand people were responding um
we've got
twenty percent biden twenty six percent
trump
these are these are would would-be biden
and would-be trump voters who are
listening to
unity 2020 yes exactly uh who are you
planning on
voting for before you found out about
unity 2020
and what you're speaking to here are the
12 percent that we're planning on not
voting for president
the 13 that we're going to write in a
vote um
not voting at all can cover a lot of
different reasons from them being
a felon and not able to vote to living
in a u.s territory that that
may not allow voting to being under the
age of 18
but this is an enormous of number which
i think is is
that 12 and that 16 these are people
engaged enough to be paying attention to
unity 2020 which
seems unlikely if they're just simply
not eligible to be voting we don't know
who these people are what they're
responding to but nonetheless it's a
large number of people who in one
category or the other
12 percent of the thousand and 16
percent were either not voting or not
voting for president
and then amongst the people who were
committed to major party candidates
twenty percent are would be biden voters
twenty six percent are would be trump
voters
so anyway uh this says that
a these things are evenly divided pretty
evenly
and b that to the extent that they are
drawing more from one side or the other
they're drawing more away from trump
than they are from biden
so i think that that really belongs in
people's mindset
the fact that we have now seen that in
multiple data sets
uh as people consider whether or not we
should be engaged in unity 2020 they
should be thinking about that
all right what else do you have for us
noah
um well let's uh let's see uh first of
all let's ask our guests
uh is there are there some other
questions we should fire off
um and if not i i do wonder if we can
look a little more closely at the
the potential uh areas of agreement here
so
uh did either of you have anything you
want us to ask right now and what i'm
going to put up on screen here
is i'm going to start sorting let's
let's sort by trump voters
and see what can you describe one value
that reaches across the aisle
um and and and you can see that the what
trump voters think reaches across the
aisle reaches across for by denial uh
and that the top issue is actually
college education and education in
general
um so but let's break this down first of
all john nate do you have a question we
should fire off to people
um yeah i do
do we feel this is a very general
question
do we feel hopeful about the future of
america
it's very very general all right we do
do we do we genuinely feel hope
it's a good one all right and then i'm
gonna ask people uh
to describe why or why not all right so
we'll get some some good data there
um i imagine you might have a lot of
people who might be tempted to say
both because a lot of times that is kind
of the real sort of thing there are
things that give us hope
and there are things that make us
pessimistic right
but in any event i'll be i'll be uh
interested to hear that hear the spread
well here's a question uh the pollster
uh would say the options are yes the
other and
no but should we put a third option
which is uh
depends on the day yeah what about what
about what about a little speak to the
question do we feel hopeful about the
future of the unity of america
i think that that is a little more
pointed and it's more what i'm kind of
alluding to
interesting right yeah all right because
it's felt like it in my
you know past i mean i think september
12th
uh 2001 was a very unified day
we've had other moments like that seems
like a lot having to do with disasters
whether they're natural or
or otherwise and then we seem to come
together in those times
for the most part it seems like it's
lessening
here more and more but uh i don't know
so that's kind of what i'm alluding to
yeah
there you go guys you're you're you're
you're you're really split
this is by by likely voter
no everybody's 30 you know pretty close
to even
uh so you can interpret that a lot of
different ways
yeah all right so i'd i'd like to
get some information in talking to
people that i know
about what they are seeing and
experiencing i'm beginning to think that
there's something about your
your friend group your spouse that
affects
whether or not you can whether or not
your eyes are openable
in other words i'm finding people who
don't have any
diversity of thought in their friend
group and they don't have
a reality check in a significant other
for example are having an almost
impossible time
resisting the social pull of
of what is overtaking us in either
direction
and so what i want to know is of the
people who are paying attention to the
unity 2020 conversation
what fraction of them have somebody in
their close circle
with whom they have substantial
disagreements but
uh get along well that's a great
question
do you have someone in your close circle
that you
have substantial political disagreements
with or does that
yeah well i would guess that we all do
yeah
um that we all do and that you know i
gotta say it doesn't throw me at all
right all day long i meet people with
whom i have substantial disagreements
and it means nothing about
whether we get along i mean
but many americans are locked i think
in an echo chamber or you know i mean
maybe
maybe um you have a relative or
something who's coming from the other
side of the
political divide and you know
you hear this person you see this person
post things on facebook now again but
for the most part you're getting the
same messages reinforced
over and over again by people who agree
with you it would be interesting to
to to get real data on that and i'm not
sure
are you aware of data like that has more
in common done that kind of research
where we analyze you know what
percentage of the american people
are in a are networked in a way to where
90 upwards of 90 95 or so
of their meaningful social relationships
are with people who think the way they
do politically
and how many have some substantial you
know
number of relationships with people who
differ within that way
is there data on that as far as you know
uh i don't know it seems to me
essential that there would be data
because just what we're seeing play out
plays out
so differently if you know if you you
know and i think actually this goes to
something that nate was saying
about the military right the military
forces you
into collaboration with people who are
across a wide spectrum now it may not be
as
wide as it might be it may borrow more
from some parts of the
political spectrum than others but it
cuts across racial lines it cuts across
class lines and um
the necessity of understanding somebody
you know you can't just decide
um that somebody who's in your unit
is a terrible person and you're not
going to collaborate with them it's just
not
the structure negates that so you have
to find the humanity in other people
in order to make it work and um
so in any case there are a small number
of things
in society that force you into that kind
of contact
and a large number that don't and my my
fear is that most people are surrounded
by people who agree with them so much
that it's very easy for them to fall
into this echo chamber thing
and it's much it's much harder if um
something about your day-to-day life
just simply violates those boundaries
well and the thing is
is the more the trends of polarization
increase the more they will increase
right because suddenly when you have
to pay a social price for being
of a minority point of view then you're
going to see solace and refuge with
folks who
agree with you right which means you're
going to vacate those spaces that would
otherwise be ideologically integrated
and i think i may have seen some data
somewhere along the way to suggest that
there's even a geographical sorting
that's kind of
taken place in that way where people are
moving to places
in part on the basis of wanting to be
around folks with whom their
politics the surrounding politics can
allow them to feel socially safe
right so i i i can't recall where i may
have seen
any of that but any of that data but it
may be out there
so yeah but we can we can imagine that
this is this pattern is
probably real and probably accelerating
um
by and large which is why building up
the counter forces to allow that trend
to go in the other direction
is important which is exactly what we
are doing here
exactly now i've been having a weird
experience
i've been uh trying to do as much biking
as i can while the sun is still shining
because
winter is coming as i keep trying to
remind my various viewers but
um and i've been looking at these signs
that people are putting in their windows
and on their lawns and things and
you know a lot of it is exactly what you
would expect you know there's a lot of
very standard black lives matter stuff
but then there's a
this class of sign that attempts to make
a different point
so a sign will very often start out with
you know
black lives matter and then it will go
on to say something about
science is very important right
something like this
and one has the sense that i mean i
can't imagine that
americans have ever accomplished very
much by dialoguing through
bumper stickers or whatever they do but
nonetheless there's an attempt to figure
out
how you can say something so that it can
be heard across a divide
right the entire the idea that black
lives matter is synonymous with
um science as white supremacist is
nonsense
right so the attempt to
deliver a message that contains
you know both something that you have to
say and some nuance that's important
to get across the divide i find hopeful
i guess right yeah
yeah well people who are interested in
brokering um one more functional
you know social relationships and two of
better politics
are interested in the project of
figuring out how do you frame things so
as to accomplish
precisely that and so that juxtaposition
which you identify is probably
a signal of somebody tried to do that
that work
nate i'm wondering if you have uh
particular tactics or
tech techniques or i mean you're such an
earnest guy man
but i'm just wondering if there are
things that you've learned along the way
in terms of how you
go about communicating these different
directions that
that come to mind they come to your mind
as things you might be able to share
with some of the folks
listening to us here i just copy people
that i respect
none of them are my own ideas i'm not
original you know
uh there's there's there's there's
people that
conduct themselves in a way that
impresses me and you know and
everybody's got their there's
not everybody has all of those qualities
uh but
certain people do certain things really
well and uh
in my opinion and so i i try to
i try to emulate that as much as i can
and uh
i try to do i try to do a really
conscious job
of of listening because i have that
personal impulse as a lot of us do
i think anybody that feels like they're
a generally
somewhat intelligent person we have this
impulse of like
you know we we want to piggyback back
off this idea or
like you know maybe we have a counter
argument like
we have that that urge to just to
definitely say something you know to
step
in and make sure that um it's validating
us for ourselves you know and it's
validated
we could validate that person as well um
but
contribute to that conversation in some
way and sometimes
uh it's just not necessary and uh you
know there's there's there's no there's
artists that i've listened to that
are incredibly smart they have this
this great presence about them um yet
they're you know their their their main
currencies are silence and stillness you
know and i watch those people and i'm
just like wow
that person is engaged that person could
probably
run circles around everybody else in
this room if they wanted to but they
don't
and it's just that uh i think it's that
bad humility that really inspires me and
i keep going back to humility but i
think that's a
it's a it's a lost art and uh it does
motivate me and it does uh
it does make me want to follow you know
i i think i think
good leaders are are great followers too
because you don't always have to take
the torch you don't always have to be in
the front
if you're a good leader you know
sometimes it's better that you're not
and you let
you know you let your tribe lead the way
and empower them
so those type of things i just i try to
do and i fail every day
you know i screw up and i and i put my
foot on my mouth and i get
so amped up and pissed off and whatever
about things and i'm just
i try to be conscious about that because
it doesn't fix anything just pure anger
and uh and debate you know uh doesn't
really fix anything
it's that it's action um and being very
deliberate about your responses and and
not letting yourself get too comfortable
that's another thing like i i
i i've done a good job in my past at
challenging myself a lot of them have
been physical challenges in a lot of
ways or strict
you know difficult mental challenges as
far as
trying to be a green beret or whatever
it is um
but when i find myself getting
comfortable
that's when i get complacent and that's
when
i start to to buy into things that maybe
aren't true
and i start to sort of drift you know to
one way or another on a certain topic
and start to form an opinion about a
group of people
instead of uh forming opinion around you
know these are individuals with
different ideas
and just because this person wears that
uniform and
chooses this way of life or or raises
that
flag or has that sign in their yard it
doesn't mean
um that i d that i maybe disagree with
or agree with
it doesn't mean that that everything
about that person is
is not valuable you know and it's it's
something i should just completely uh
write off because i
have a tendency to do that i think a lot
of us we do it's human nature we want to
we want to to categorize everything
and uh yeah i just i'm a copycat i
do my best to follow people that inspire
me you gentlemen are two of those people
i mean the way that you speak the way
that you think about things
how articulate you are it's something
that i'm not necessarily great at so
i try to listen and then i try to speak
from the heart
and just be as genuine as possible i'm
not good at
anything scripted i'm not good at
memorization when it comes to that i
just
i want to speak how i feel and that
makes me feel better
and hopefully it you know it
resonates with some people you
underestimate yourself mr boyer
and uh yeah i'm very uh very moved and
persuaded by the way you explain the
vital importance of humility which is
why i'm so
proud that i'm always the most humble
person in any room i walk into
that's great i just you know i have no
one is more humble than me though
well i mean i beg the difference sir
but ironically it's key to leadership
isn't it well i'm
sure there's some evolutionary
biological explanation for why that
might be
no i want to unpack it a little bit
because i think that there's something
very deep here but i often hear it
misportrayed
right like there's you know it's like do
you sound
humble i i don't care what i really
want are leaders that um
are not ego driven i want somebody who
knows what they're capable of and has
nothing to prove
and actually the flip side of this an
insecure leader
i find very dangerous and i see this in
trump and i saw it in bill clinton
there's just something about the
need to prove something that causes them
to be willing to do terrible harm
in order to deal with some demon in
their past
and what i really want is a leader who's
just not even focused on that right
they're really interested in figuring
out do i have the skills to do this if i
don't know the answer who can i talk to
that'll inform me i want that person
where
you know i don't want somebody who isn't
self-confident that's what we tend to
get from this
claim about humbleness i want somebody
who has self-confidence
but has it it's earned and they've got
nothing to prove to anybody
and that's going to make them capable of
the kind of leadership that we need
so anyway i just uh if we're going to
sign up for
humble as an important characteristics i
want to sign up for the right
kind of humble where it emerges from
just
being secure rather than being reflexive
and
uh you know trying to prove that you're
not ego driven that's
that's bad would you say that a
component don't know i was
gonna say i think people can see that i
think most people can see
that genuine you know the genuine
humility versus uh
that mask i guess you know to cover deep
insecurity you know the front i i i
think
i think most of us most of us get that
and see that
um and i just you know going back to the
military thing that
i i will always place the mission first
is one of the first things
you learn is instilled in you in basic
training
you know and they say it over and over
and over and you you genuinely start to
believe that
and uh the mission is about it's about
the team
it's the overall um what is the greatest
good for the greatest amount
of people it is not
what what uh it's not placing me first
certainly uh and it's not it's not this
this idea that we all have as human
beings of
uh everything that we do is you know we
want to look good and we want to feel
good
we can't help that that's in us we do a
lot of times people are charitable
because it makes them feel good i mean
i've done things that
that are that are charitable for selfish
reasons before too because it makes me
feel good it's not bad that you're doing
that
but that's a genuine thing
in the military that was you know it's
instilled in you at such a high level
uh and from day one that you understand
if
you don't pull your weight if you don't
do your part for the team for the
mission
something goes wrong you're gonna live
with that
the fact that it was your it was on your
watch it was your fault you didn't do
your job to the best of your ability for
everybody else
it wasn't about you because if we fail
for ourselves we screw up and it only
affects us
it doesn't really bother us you know if
we screw up and it affects the team
it affects the country in some way oh
you know or we lose a comrade that's
that that that kills us you know it eats
us alive and it stays with us forever so
that's the kind of mindset that has to
go into leadership
at a political level i think it really
has to be
yep yeah noah do you have uh do you have
data for us
oh man we've got we got a lot of data um
on the screen
uh one thing i wanted to say is one of
the most popular answers i asked
the peop asked everyone um the question
was uh how do we increase humility among
americans and uh
67 percent of people agreed with this
nice
quote which is more conversations like
this one
when you hear someone who's extremely
good at bringing people together it puts
you in the mindset
that you need to improve this capacity
yourself
um so i thought that was a little good
vibes and you all might appreciate that
um we also asked a few other questions
which is uh which we can dive into
um uh right up here uh
john suggested we needed to understand
each other's starting points what do you
think now i haven't looked at what
people said so it might
we'll see what they say um there's a lot
of agreement uh that we need more
empathy
and um the the another most popular
answer is i think this is getting to
bedrock
living increasingly in our own silos
we've lost empathy
empathy for other people um absolutely
true empathy requires being able to
understand
um how an individual came to be so um
what i want to say is john amongst the
people on this call uh they
they uh they agree with you um so i want
to pause there and
point something else out that's
important which is that this process
whereby we lose track of empathy for
other people
actually reliably precedes war
in other words before one population
goes to war
against another or engages in genocide
against another
it portrays it as sub-human as diseased
as vermin these are very common tropes
and so
what i would say is it's very ominous
that we are now
hearing this kind of thinking inside of
our political structure
because what it tells us is that we are
engaging the circuitry
that leads people to war and for that to
occur inside of the american political
structure is
frightening i mean not just for us
americans but for people around the
world who know
how important it is that america does
not tear itself apart
now you know what's interesting i have
heard people obviously i'm very much the
very much a sort of champion of of
empathy right and i'm heartened by the
uh folks responses here um i have heard
arguments that have tried to make the
case that empathy
is in fact a dangerous thing because it
is in fact
empathy itself that leads to those
preconditions that yield war
because when people find themselves
empathizing
so much with the in-group they go to war
with the out group
which to me almost seems like a bit of
sleight of hand is an argument because
even within the statement there is the
clear break of empathy with folks in the
out group in other words the problem i
don't think is
too much empathy on the in group it is
it is the lack of empathy with the out
group
but i have also heard and maybe this is
paul bloom or somebody saying this i'm
not sure
but i have also heard it argued that
well
empathy with the out group can
precipitate
conflict if we have a sort of empathy
where we get so wrapped up in say the
suffering
of just for example uh you know
um oppressed
population in iraq let's say that we
support you know armed intervention in a
way that winds up costing many more
lives than we
then we save in a certain context
because we're so concerned with the
suffering of a small group of people
that we're willing to you know break the
well-being of a much greater
group uh i'm just wondering brett uh how
you deal with those uh
those objections well uh it's a great
question
and there is actually now well
understood
i would recommend people read robert
sapolsky's book behave
where he he covers this in depth and you
know it used to be that we thought that
oxytocin
the hormone was the love hormone that it
was the bonding hormone which it is
but it's not just the bonding hormone
it's the in-group out-group hormone
and so the this molecule that is
released
when a mother bonds with her baby is
also
involved in the recognizing something as
the enemy
so is that also the molecule i get when
i bite into this chocolate cupcake
nope that's good that's liable to be at
least a certain amount of dopamine
but uh anyway enjoy somebody yeah but
anyway what i would say is we are
very plastic creatures we can
regard a very tiny number as in group
and everybody else is out group
or we can increasingly in group people
who are more and more distant from us so
this is sort of
you know i see this encapsulated in
christianity in
you know the two stories um
uh you know jesus tale of the the good
samaritan
is one and and the invocation of the
golden rule these are both instances
where
the the in-group expands right
um now ultimately the question is can
the in-group be expanded
all the way and should it be and
you know this is not an immediate
suggestion but there's something about
the peril that we all
share as you know creatures
fighting against incredible odds over
the long term
um trapped on a planet together that we
are now
uh spending into oblivion behaving very
unsustainably
if we recognize the jeopardy that we are
putting
all of our all of us in by fighting
between us rather than recognizing that
at some level
it must be true that sustainability will
either
be the mode that we discover or we will
destroy ourselves
one way or another that that could
result
in us in grouping humanity
now this is a discussion from another
time you have to do it very carefully
or it will be self-unstable but
ultimately i do think that that's
what we should be heading for is a
recognition that um
what we have is the result of having
recognized a larger and larger
set of people as within our in group and
that ultimately
the best and probably only stable end
point is to recognize
we are all in group and that our
long-term well-being depends
on us standing down the competitive
dynamics
that threaten us while retaining the
competitive dynamics
that allow us to discover new ways of
being and to thrive
can i add a data point that supports
that which is we just
asked other than announced candidates
what would be the best
thing unity2020 could do to increase
support
uh 70 percent 77 percent of people the
most pop
second most popular answer uh was i'm
scared of promoting it because i don't
know
what to do i want a step-by-step guide
for talking to my friends and family
because i'm nervous
so this actually
suggests a line of questioning i was
hoping we would get to
which is i have the sense that those of
us in the unity
conversation recognize that none of the
standard answers
neither one blue or red is the least bit
safe
and the disaster may be very different
but it's still a disaster coming either
way
but most of the people we engage with
who are not unity-minded
yet are able to see one of the disasters
and incapable of seeing the other and
that's the reason that they're so hard
to reach
and so the question i want to ask first
of
of john and nate and then of the
audience if it's possible to do it
is what is it if you're one of these
blue no matter who voters
right where you see trump as the problem
and your sense is well until that
problem's gone
i'm voting blue and i don't care about
the details
what can you say to such a person that
will allow them to
see the danger of that solution
if they see the trump danger and they
can't see the biden danger what will
allow them to see it
and then the flip side is if you see the
danger
of the biden answer here and you think
you know maybe you're one of these
voters who
isn't in love with the trump solution
but you recognize it as at least a break
from
uh the standard pattern what can be said
to those voters so that they can see the
hazard of continuing
another four years down this road
so let me let me engage that and and
actually brett i'm i'm
i'm i'm at the maximum of my my time uh
if you if you'll forgive me i'll
probably have to step away after this
um but this has been terrific and and
let me let me engage
that in the context of uh
trump voters here but the principle will
clearly be
applicable across the board i think um
a lot of folks and i say this you know
with
absolutely no judgment or condemnation
of folks voting for trump or
biden uh or anybody else um
but a lot of folks felt that they had to
kind of sidestep their
normal sort of uh conscience or
barometer for evaluating the behavior of
a candidate who they could wholly feel
good about supporting because the threat
from the left was so imminent that they
felt like they had to back a person who
was going to be a useful bludgeon
against destructive forces in society
and he was standing up for policies
that mattered to them right and so for a
period of time
the economy was good we have
conservative justices on the bench and
so forth from that
from that angle trump presidency was
arguably successful up until
other things happened right but the
thing that i always
argued in all directions is that
ultimately
a prosperous society a society whose
political and other institutions are
functioning well
and serving us is only sustainable in a
cultural in a cultural
context in which the american people are
working well together
based on the strength of our
interpersonal and our intergroup
relationships when that deteriorates
when that breaks down
the only thing that may hold us together
to a degree for a while
is material prosperity but what happens
behind the scenes of that
is that we're all seeking to sabotage
each other politically
and to punish each other socially and so
when that disappears our ability to
collaborate
on meaningful things necessary to the
survival and prosperity of our country
uh disappears that is what i said
well before the advent of covet 19. that
is what i said
well before our inability to marshal a
collective societal response
to you know a health threat which has
been obviously
it's far beyond just being a threat to
public health it has crashed
the american economy in a way that
hasn't happened since
the great depression and whether you
think that we should have gone right or
left in our policy response to
to that and how we implemented counter
measures
the fact is is that any meaningful way
of engaging a response there would have
required
the strong consensus of the american
people politically in a way that
would have necessitated some minimum
threshold of civic trust to exist
between us
on a social and a cultural level and
that is obliterated
when we put our faith in parties and
politicians that are
situated in such a way to where their
pathway towards success and influence is
predicated
on division as opposed to fostering
unity and so the more we
invest our political and our social
capital
and and and confidence in in those sorts
of politicians
in those sorts of political parties
parties can change
right but in those sorts of structures
um the more we
ensure that that is going to be the
pathway to our demise and the only
meaningful thing that we're choosing
between
when we choose between different
variations of those alternatives is
perhaps what the timeline looks like or
just how exactly that winds up
expressing itself
and so yeah i mean i've actually been
making this argument
well before unity 2020 because even
beyond beyond unity 2020
it is again a question of what sort of
politics
do we want to stand for on the base most
cultural foundation most cultural level
right and we need to stand for a
politics that strengthens our
relationships as a people
rather than destroys them so that's my
closing speech beautiful
beautiful nate do you want to go and
then we will close this out and
uh to the extent that we didn't collect
all of the data i
i think we will tweet it out using our
uh twitter account but nate
go for it yeah i mean that's uh you said
of a lot of it right there
and i think uh
it gets it's too it's to the point well
it's been to the point but
in this situation like we've got uh
we've got our guy
the guy we're going for the guy you know
the guy we're voting for
and we're all in on that
it's all going to be that and and if our
guy wins great
but if you think that it's just
going to be
calm or better or good for the next four
years
once that happens you're in for a rude
awakening
because the moment that starts whether
it's trump whether it's biden
the attacks continue they'll probably
elevate they'll probably escalate
they're gonna
they're not slowing down and it's going
to be this continued
50 50 split um and
it's just it's just ugly it's it's ugly
and and there's never going to and it's
going to come from the media
it's going to come from everywhere else
and it's just this cycle that will not
stop
until we stop it and you know
picking that picking that side because
uh you know you feel especially because
you feel
well i can't go with this guy because i
mean he's going to destroy the country
so i got to go with this other guy
neither of these guys are going to
destroy the country we are destroying
the country
we're doing it ourselves you know it's
on us it's our responsibility and we
have
the power to change it that's what's
great about america we do have the power
to change that it's in our hands
uh but we're you know but we're not
accepting that we're we're giving that
power up because we feel
our list we feel like we don't have
the the the aptitude to to change it and
it's it's uh it's
it hurts it just hurts to to know that
that's how people feel
that hopelessness and i mean that's one
of the main reasons i wanted to ask that
question about about hopefulness because
i actually feel
that hopefulness um i i just
don't feel it in the masses
it's not that i don't think they're
capable i just don't think they
understand or know
that or believe in any way that it is
possible and i know it's possible
because i've seen people change i've
seen things radically
shift in a short period of time um you
know not maybe at a national level like
this
just a few couple of months before the
an election
but uh when people get to a point where
they finally see and believe how broken
things are
and how painful it is to live to live in
this place right now
uh and how frustrating it is you know i
think that
their eyes may be open they may be
willing to listen to
to something that's that's pretty pretty
opposite of what they're accustomed to
and uh i just i think it's necessary
it's absolutely necessary we've got to
rip the band-aids off and start over
um but it's just it's going to take a
lot of people
on board to do it beautiful amen
um there is a hopi saying or at least
frequently attributed to hopi elders
which i really like which is we are the
ones we've been waiting for
and i think at some level that uh nicely
bridges the two final statements you've
just given and
i hope we do it um thank you both for
joining us this was really spectacular
i will say the metaphor of of uh
campfire was chosen for a number of
reasons one of them had to do with the
ability to take
embers from a fire and start another one
and i would encourage people
who have gotten something from this
conversation to see if you can't start a
difficult conversation
with somebody you don't fully agree with
somewhere and
if it works out or if it doesn't let us
know what happened we'd be very curious
about that
so you can find us at um twitter handle
articles of unity you can find us on the
web at articlesofunity.org
and let's uh let's do this because
it ain't gonna get any easier all right
thank you thanks guys thank you thank
you john thank you thank you
all right be well
[Music]
my
[Music]